[Musica]
voi
ritiene il tartufo
un bene di lusso
e chi di voi
ritiene la assorbente femminile un bene
di lusso
la maggior parte di noi se questo fosse
stato un esame non lo avrebbe passato sì
perché in italia il tartufo
viene tassato solo al 5 per cento
gli assorbenti essendo un bene di lusso
no chi tra il tartufo le assorbente non
sceglierebbe l'assorbente
viene passato al 22 per cento
ecco questo è un esempio di tassa rosa
la pink tax ma che cos'è la tassa rosa è
un fenomeno che ha in tutto il mondo
cioè non è solo questa tassa e quindi
l'iva ma sono anche prodotti simili ma
quindi con simili qualità ma che
cambiano di prezzo in base al
consumatore al genere del consumatore
ovvero se una donna paga di più
facciamo un esempio i rasoi
parliamo di rasoi classici non quelli
complicati basici il classico rasoio blu
sapevate che c'è una media di differenza
dell'undici per cento con il rasoio rosa
ma non sono solo i rasoi
ci sono gli champs
ci sono le creme
addirittura e mouse del computer quello
nero
costa meno di quello rosa allora la
domanda è ma forse il colore rosa e così
caro mi sono informata non è così
cioè come mai tutto ciò avviene perché i
numeri parlano chiaro sono numeri molto
alti cioè in italia c'è una differenza
hanno cioè noi paghiamo noi donne in più
1400 euro per la tassa rosa negli stati
uniti siamo un po meglio mi intorno ai
1.300 dollari
e allora cosa c'è dietro
a questa tassa rosa perché
determinati oggetti e servizi mi ero
dimenticata e servizi attenzione non
solo il meccanico che ormai insomma lo
sappiamo un po tutti ma ad esempio se
portiamo una classica camicia che ormai
quelle tra uomo e donna quelle basi che
non sono molto differenti diciamo di
jeans in lavanderia
dovete sapere che quelle da donna
costano di più
io quando ho scoperto questo discorso
della tassa rosa in america a un mio
amico gli ho detto senti da ora in poi
portate le mie camicie effettivamente
c'è stato il risparmio
allora come mai c'è il discorso della
tassa rosa cosa c'è dietro questa tassa
rosa
ma si parla che noi donne amiamo
spendere di più
secondo me non è così
o che siamo più facilone o che non
rinunciamo a comprare
secondo me invece
c'è sempre una regola che è follow the
money segui i soldi
infatti in italia se non ci fosse la
tassa rosa ci sarebbe una perdita di 50
milioni di euro annui 50 milioni di euro
che paghiamo noi
noi donne
interessante però siccome a noi ci piace
sempre vedere la luce in fondo al tunnel
dobbiamo anche dire che c'è un movimento
che c'è un piccolo cambiamento infatti
in scozia nel 2020 gli assorbenti sono
gratuiti nel regno unito nel 2021 hanno
abolito la tassa sugli assorbenti allora
quindi la conclusione è che noi donne
paghiamo di più allora se paghiamo di
più
guadagneremo di più giusto
errato
anche in questo caso c'è il divario
retributivo di genere
e la media in europa cioè cosa vuol dire
analizziamole esattamente che due
persone che hanno bene o male la stessa
qualifica che fanno lo stesso lavoro e
che hanno più o meno lo stesso
curriculum uno guadagna di più in base
al suo genere e uno guadagna di meno
indovinate chi è che guadagna di meno
noi le donne e la media in europa è del
14 per cento
allora dice beh ma non è tanto non ho i
numeri sono molto alti negli stati uniti
è stato fatto uno studio
e questo il risultato che in un anno noi
guadagniamo meno di media 11 mila 400
dollari all'anno dovute al nostro genere
attenzione non alle nostre qualità
lavorative o meno e nell'arco di una
carriera lavorativa si parla di
850mila dollari in meno
850mila dollari meno
tantissimo più di una casa
ecco allora
la conclusione è va bene ma allora se
noi guadagniamo di meno paghiamo di più
possiamo avere magari più opportunità
nella nostra carriera avere un
avanzamento di carriera è no
anche in questo caso
abbiamo il soffitto di vetro
che cos'è il soffitto di vetro
immaginatevi che sopra di voi c'è un
vetro un vetro fortissimo e noi donne
stiamo lì a picconarla giorno e notte
ma è un vero come quello blindato lo
possiamo scalfire qua e là certo alcune
di noi ce la fanno
cioè noi abbiamo difficoltà non ci viene
data la possibilità di diventare ad
esempio sia o di aziende
presidenti di aziende ecco che
in questo caso il soffitto di vetro e
anche in questo caso è un fenomeno
globale infatti ed classi
alcune donne ce l'hanno fatta
macché costo a che prezzo
perché noi donne e ve ne parlo in prima
persona
noi donne per per rompere quel vetro
dobbiamo lavorare non il doppio il
triplo dobbiamo dimostrare e dobbiamo
rinunciare a tanto ha tantissimo ecco
perché molte di noi donne che magari
hanno dei successi lavorativi poi sono
estremamente sole perché dobbiamo
rinunciare non c'è spazio per tutto ecco
questo è il
soffitto di vetro
infatti secondo il forcing di quest'anno
su 500 amminis su 500 società gli
amministratori delegati uomini sono
459 mentre le donne solo 41
quindi diciamo intorno all 8 per cento e
in italia com'è la situazione speriamo
che nel bel paese la situazione sia
migliore che ne pensate
no questo avete risposto giusto e
infatti in italia nel 20 20 e solo il 2
per cento
solo il 2 per cento nelle sono
amministratrici delegate
e adesso parliamo invece
come possiamo risolverla questa
situazione beh allora ricapitoliamo mi
sembra la canzone alla fiera dell'est
allora guadagniamo di meno
spendiamo di più ci costa tutto di più
non abbiamo un escalation lavorativa
opportunità lavorative allora
proviamo
a cambiare le leggi perché non le
abbiamo cambiate le leggi interveniamo
nei governi
allora in italia netto a paragone due
paesi a mccurry 1 l'italia dove sono
nata un sono gli stati uniti dove abito
in italia in 73 anni ci sono stati 12
presidenti negli stati uniti in 232 anni
ci sono stati 46 presidenti 46
123 da insieme a me 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 20 33
40 41 42 43 45 46 quante donne sono
state presidenti
prima ministra in italia
e allora ricapitolando paghiamo di più
guadagnano di meno non abbiamo
l'escalation
lavorativa e in più possiamo entrare nel
governo in italia si obblighiamo con le
quote rosa
e allora le nazioni unite hanno detto
che
se continuiamo di questo passo e se
siamo fortunati perché il covip ci ha
rallentato nell'uguaglianza
ci vorranno esattamente 130 anni non li
stiamo a contare ora ma 130 anni sono
tantissimi
vuol dire che le vostre figlie non
vedranno l'uguaglianza le vostre nipoti
nemmeno le vostre pronipoti annuseranno
sempre che non ci sia un blocco
e allora che cosa possiamo fare perché
noi in questo ted ex chiediamo so e ora
cosa possiamo fare now ott
allora io ho pensato a un pensato e
ripensato perché sapete che il mio
lavoro sono in prima linea attraverso la
narrativa dei film e per l'uguaglianza
di genere
pensando ecco ecco la risposta
questa è la risposta
una slide nera perché perché è un
problema complicato complesso che
riguarda tutto il mondo e quindi non c'è
una risposta che possiamo dare ma è un
percorso
e questo percorso lo possiamo fare solo
tutti insieme dove ogni individuo fa la
sua parte dobbiamo cambiare la cultura
perché risolvere un problema prima
bisogna capire che abbiamo questo
problema e quindi adesso siamo nella
fase a mio avviso della consapevolezza
io ci credo che ce la faremo e ce la
metto tutta e allora se dovessi pensare
a un immagine
di questo viaggio
dell'uguaglianza mi verrebbe in mente mi
viene in mente una montagna una montagna
gigantesca e ha grandissima più
dell'everest
e laggiù in vetta ci dobbiamo arrivare
però non posso guardare in alto perché
se guardo in alto io ho paura perché
troppo lontano troppo difficile e se lo
faccio da sola io ho paura e allora solo
tutti insieme possiamo iniziare
passo dopo passo passo dopo passo e non
dobbiamo mai guardarci indietro perché
se ci guardiamo indietro al passato il
passato già non esiste dobbiamo guardare
al futuro e se qualcuno di noi non
volesse più proseguire non possiamo
fermarci dobbiamo continuare
e dobbiamo arrivare lì su in vetta
perché lì ci sarà il panorama più bello
che abbiamo visto il panorama dove ogni
essere umano
ha un'opportunità di uguaglianza perché
oggigiorno
noi siamo ancora noi donne considerate
una minoranza quando di fatto siamo una
maggioranza rappresentiamo dal dal 50 al
51 per cento della popolazione
e quindi io credo che tutti insieme ed è
una scelta comune
e sarà anche un viaggio molto bello di
crescita perché quando una società è
inclusa si va e quando in una società
c'è il valore della uguaglianza è una
società migliore per gli uomini per le
donne per tutti quanti noi e quindi
insieme arriviamo a questa vetta perché
lugo alleanza è un diritto di ogni
essere umano
[Applauso]
[Musica]